- Once all the Christmas
songs start coming on
the first thing I can think of is
when are we gonna get to January second,
like can this all be over soon.
- Hi.
I'm Matt, and my parents got divorced
when I was eight years old.
Now I know no two divorces are the same.
But if there's any time
of year that unifies
people with divorced
parents, it's the holidays.
And the fact that they're
pretty complicated.
So I asked some of my
coworkers with divorced parents
to share some of their experiences
and feelings towards the holiday season.
And how it's changed
from when they were kids,
to now as adults.
- I'm Logan, my parents got divorced
when I was about five years old.
- I'm Jamie, I'm 27, my parents
divorced when I was five.
- Hi my name's Lindsey, I was 21
when my parents got divorced.
- My name's Alp, I am
currently 27 years old,
and I was six years old when
my parents got divorced.
- So I'm Emily, I was four
when my parents got divorced.
- I'm Chelsea, my parents got
divorced, when I was like,
oh they got separated when
I was like eight or nine,
and then didn't officially
get divorced til
I was 15 cause shit's messy.
- I don't really remember
them together at all,
which means I only really
know spending Christmas
with both of them, meaning
I had two Christmases.
- It never really affected Christmas,
other than the fact that I
had a lot of extra presents.
- Now that they're divorced, I'm an adult,
the holidays are extremely inconvenient.
- In a weird way I feel
fortunate because I was so young
and you know when you're that age,
like things don't feel weird,
that's just your family.
And that's just your day to day life.
- The holidays were weird because,
like I didn't have memories
from when they were together,
so I always thought that people would
go to one house one year and
then another house another year
and then I grew up and was like wait...
- The biggest thing I think in retrospect
that like I really wanted to
do was maintain traditions.
I do have memories of being like,
well my dad's not part
of the Christmas anymore,
who's gonna fill my mom's stocking
and give her like, pajamas
and Santa presents.
- As you get older having
divorced parents sucks.
Because you essentially
have to pick one parent.
- I have had a lot of step
parents over the years,
five to be exact.
- So just rolling between, two households,
driving and staying sober at one or the other,
which is hard enough as it
is without divorced parents.
- It's always better to
have more support around you
growing up as a child I think,
but I was really happy
that they were both happy.
- Now I kind of don't like the holidays,
because it makes me feel tired I guess.
- If you're dating or in a relationship
with someone who also
has divorced parents,
it really sucks cause
then you have four parents
to deal with and you
essentially have to choose
one of them and you
feel like you're always
gonna hurt someone's feelings essentially.
- When I was growing up we had like,
exciting, fun, big holidays,
big Italian family,
everyone in one place usually,
in my parent's home, so
now that's different.
And a lot less fun.
- One thing that is cool,
about having two separate
families during the holidays is that
you get to spend a lot of
time with your siblings
kind of bonding over the
shared weird experience
that you're all going through.
- It like started being
okay when we just kind of
stopped trying to combine it in any way.
And I'd have like lunch
or something with my dad.
- If you have siblings
it's just a giant mess.
So when you're young it's
cool to have two Christmases,
but as you get older, it
becomes really complicated.
- I actually love Christmas,
I've never disliked it.
I put my tree up two days
after Thanksgiving, this year.
But I haven't spent Christmas
with family since 2009.
- Yeah it is a little
weird to juggle your time.
And keeping two sides
of the family separate,
so I don't know, I guess
it is normal to feel like,
you have to sacrifice
your personal desires
to do things that are right
for your family members
and everybody's comfortable in the space.
- When you're a kid you're
just super sheltered,
and you, again, just don't
really realize what's not normal.
So I think growing up
that kind of clicked.
Being like oh I don't
have to do this anymore.
I don't have to spend all my
time worrying about family
matters and all that
stuff, and I guess I just
chose to be indifferent
about the holidays.
- I could just like
ignore all the problems
if we just separated it and
weren't trying to bounce around.
- The holidays now are
kinda like a mixed bag
because it's kinda nice
to see parents that
you don't see all the
time when you're an adult.
Especially if you don't live
in the same state as them.
But it really just becomes
a scheduling nightmare
trying to figure out things cause
you don't get a lot of time off,
but you wanna see your parents.
- I have a good
relationship with my family.
I call them I talk to them.
But we're not very celebratory together.
- The general feeling I
have of my parents divorce
is a feeling of like, I
feel it was the right thing.
And I think I benefited
growing up from that choice.
- I don't know, it's hard,
it's complicated I guess.
I think as an adult, I, feel like,
especially cause I live
3,000 miles away from home,
and so when I go home I wanna see
also my friends and balancing that
with seeing like my extended family.
- You kind of feel like
a child at some times
cause it's like well I
was with mom last year,
this year I have to be with dad.
- Once all the Christmas
songs start coming on
the first thing I can think of is
when are we gonna get to January second,
like can this all be over soon.
- I've always liked tradition,
which I think is why
I haven't minded that I haven't
spent Christmas with family.
Cause I started my own traditions.
I usually spend it with friends.
- Yeah in the long run, I
think holidays are such a small
part of what it is to be a family.
I wouldn't say I'm jaded
about the holidays,
like, I think it's appropriate
to call me a grinch
or whatever, but, there
are so many other moments
to share with my family,
that Christmas or Easter,
or whatever isn't really the biggest part
that I feel bringing us together.
- Oh yeah, I think that
everything I've said
wouldn't offend my mom, so that's good.
- [Interviewer] That's a relief.